[Música]
e
este vídeo dura 37 segundos
tan solo 37 segundos
estamos el rosario argentina
es agosto del 2013
la fuga de gas
la explosión derrumbe 22 muertos tal vez
la tragedia más grande de argentina
y yo solo pude grabar 37 segundos
en ese momento no sé por qué dejé de
grabar o tal vez cuando pasó el tiempo
pudo obtener algún tipo de respuesta
sólo 37 segundos
un periodista es
una cámara con ojos
que sale de su lugar de comodidad
para ponerse incómodo
eso dice leila guerriero la gran
cronista argentina y es extraño los
periodistas nos preparamos toda una vida
para salir a contar algo que todavía no
ocurrió
y muchas veces son tragedias son
momentos límites
esa mañana de agosto yo estaba en mi
casa a 6 o 7 cuadras del lugar de
escuché la explosión estaba escribiendo
me movió unos diez centímetros hacia
atrás
pensé que pues se podía haber caído una
viga de un edificio en construcción en
frente de mi casa miré por la ventana no
vi nada
seguí escribiendo hasta que empezaron a
sonar las sirenas de los bomberos y de
las ambulancias
en ese momento recibo una llamada
de la redacción de un medio de buenos
aires
me preguntan qué es lo que estaba
pasando
leo un tuit el primer tuit hablaba de
una caldera de la explosión de una
caldera y yo tenía mi mochila preparada
como siempre una libreta para apuntes
una cámara de fotos un grabador
ese día iba a entrevistar al líder de
los palmeras justamente
estaban dando un curso de como una banda
de cumbia se podía transformar en una
pyme
y la realidad cambia así abruptamente
empecé a caminar ya cuando llegué a la
calle balcarce y brawn a la altura del
comedor balcarce se veía los vidrios
rotos
y se me cortó la señal que desconectado
con ese medio
iba a ser una cobertura sin saber para
qué medio iba a estar trabajando
cuando llegue a salta y balcarce todavía
no había vallas había pasado hacía muy
poquito tiempo
llegué a la esquina que más camina en mi
vida
porque en mis épocas de estudiante vivía
ahí en ese edificio en salt y balcarce
los protagonistas de la tragedia eran
mis propios vecinos la rodillera la
farmacéutica
nunca había visto tanta gente en estado
de shock
yo mismo estaba en estado de shock y
perdía absolutamente la dimensión de
tiempo y de espacio
no sé cuánto tiempo justamente pasó
hasta que logré obtener el primer
testimonio y era un testimonio de vida
en medio de tanta muerte un colega
me dice ahí hay un sobreviviente
estaba con la mamá y con la novia
me acerco
la novia me dice que soy un impertinente
tenía razón eso hacemos los periodistas
me re traigo hasta que franco
se acercó
y me contó parte de lo que había pasado
ahí descubrir la historia del hombre que
se despertó al borde del precipicio
la madre y la novia de francos se mueven
con el impulso que empuja la
desesperación van y avanzan entre los
cables cortados los vidrios rotos los
ecos de un estruendo inaugural el
panorama es desolador
los periodistas buscamos un número el
número de muertos que nos dé la magnitud
real de los casos dicen 20 30 40 como si
la tragedia fuera una lotería
los familiares que corren hasta salta y
oro no quieren ver tocar y abrazar a sus
seres queridos
florencia y eugenia no quieren que
franco está en la lista que buscamos los
periodistas franco sal al pueblo de un
balcón que no existe franco grita que
está vivo porque vive
en la lotería de la vida francos sólo
tiene un manchón de sangre en las
tragedias no hay moralejas en las
tragedias no hay estereotipos por buenos
no hay malos las tragedias son
tautológicas son tragedias
un año antes en el 2012 cuando se
cumplía el aniversario número 18 del
atentado a la amia me había tocado
investigar sobre protocolos de rescate
porque quería contar la historia de
alejandro un amigo un triatleta
en el triatlón hay valores en el
triatlón se administra el dolor en el
triatlón
efe
y hay resistencia alejandro
era mi compañero en el triatlón allá por
los 90 cuando todavía no existían las
bebidas isotónicas ni las zapatillas con
cámara de aire los recuerdos siempre con
una camiseta que decía a muerte de
triatlón
esa mañana de julio
de la cadete en la amia llegó
se tomó el ascensor como siempre
y no sabía qué era lo que iba a pasar
alejandro todavía no sabe que será
rescatado por los bomberos que su madre
lo verá por televisión sin reconocer lo
que será trasladado de urgencia que
estará alojado en la habitación 6.115
que sufrió fractura múltiple de tibio y
peroné en la pierna derecha que la
poesía en la carta ya se está
escribiendo y que más allá del ascensor
y su terrible historia personal afuera
hay un verdadero infierno el ascensor no
es el castigo divino es el comienzo del
milagro fue en otro abril pero en el 95
que alejandro volvió a participar fue en
el triatlón de chascomús y durante la
prueba se deshizo de las muletas cuando
aún faltaban algunos kilómetros para
llegar no fue necesaria la música de
vangelis alejandro volvió
por que narramos las historias que
narramos
francos y alejandro
dos nombres propios franco y alejandro
dos sobrevivientes mi viejo roberto
crea médico médico de pueblo en colon
provincia de buenos aires le decían el
doctor de los pobres había más
bicicletas en el consultorio de mi viejo
que en el hospital así lo recuerda
siempre me contaba una historia era un
gran narrador de historias el que
estudió en la universidad pública de
buenos aires en la década del 50
compartió algunas jornadas con el
pediatra florencio escardó
florencio escardó tuvo una gran idea muy
sencilla pero muy innovadora
en los hospitales donde estaban las
camitas de los niños mandó a sacar los
números
y los reemplazó con los nombres de los
chicos entonces ya no era el paciente de
la cama 1 de la cama 4 de la cama 5 eran
pedro lucía josé era un franco eran
alejados
y nosotros en los medios hablamos de
casos cuántas veces nos falta ponerle
nombres a las personas a los
protagonistas de nuestras historias
en los medios hay ciertas verdades
absolutas que son incuestionables y se
lo digo yo que trabaja en crónica
televisión durante 4 años y a veces nos
hacemos preguntas innecesarias
y les quiero decir algo más esas
verdades absolutas son el nombre de la
audiencia el nombre de ustedes hay una
jactancia
la gente quiere morbo
no necesitamos títulos que generen
impactos es así
pero quieren eso pensemos que nos están
escuchando gerentes de medios
necesita necesitamos ver un cadáver en
la tapa de un diario nosotros somo
cronistas cuando estamos en la calle
muchas veces tenemos datos que son muy
escuetos una vez me pasó que tenía un
dato una persona muerta en una junta de
cuentas
en la zona oeste de rosario
cuando llegue al lugar junto con mi
camarógrafo carlos
nos dimos cuenta que eso no era así
era la historia de mercedes delgado
una militante social
asesinada por balas narcos
y cuando llegamos al centro comunitario
sus compañeras
hicieron una pregunta porque vienen
ahora sí acá nosotros jugamos con los
niños le damos de comer
incluso hasta toman la comunión
pero vienen ahora
porque los periodistas llegamos tarde
ahora hay banderines amarillos y blancos
que cuelgan de otra celebración hay
lágrimas y abrazos que contienen el
desgarro hay oraciones con artículos
balbuceos impotencias verbos en pasado
hay monjas niños obreros dirigentes
gremiales hijos y compañeras hay
carteles con dibujos y deseos pegados en
las paredes de cemento hay canciones
rizadas a viva voz hay un ataúd cerrado
con una mujer muerta de dos tiros hay
una comunidad un vecindario un grupo de
mujeres mamás militantes malabaristas
que hablan susurran y alzan las palabras
como pueden tratando de reconstruir lo
que ocurrió hace algunas horas el crimen
de mercedes delgado las historias no
comienzan cuando llegan el narrador y
las historias continúan cuando los
narradores nos marchamos
como cronistas deberíamos llegar antes
nunca la pude conocer a mercedes delgado
y tal vez deberíamos ser los últimos en
irnos una vez
estaba cubriendo una nota color así le
llamamos en la tele a aquellas noticias
más pasatistas había llegado una zorra
conoce en este vehículo que sirve para
ir limpiando las las vías y nosotros
inauguramos un sistema tecnológico que
era de vanguardia en ese momento que
eran las cámaras 3g con los cual no
podíamos salir en vivo esto que hacemos
ahora con los celulares todo el tiempo
en el medio de esa nota mi hijo cumplía
dos años bautice y aproveché para
mandarle un saludo en vivo y en directo
cuando llegué a mi casa le pregunté
le digo bautice viste que papá te saludo
para el cumple si papá no escuchaste lo
que yo te dije claro
no lo había escuchado y no podía
mentirle
al periodismo le hace falta desarrollar
más sentidos
necesitamos un periodismo mucho más
sensorial varios años atrás más de diez
me tocó entrevistar a un ex combatiente
de malvinas
yo tenía la edad de mi hijo cuando
ocurrió malvinas tenía ocho años
en la entrevista me emocioné muchísimo
y cuando termino mi jefe me pregunto
dice te emocionaste no sí claro tuviste
ganas de abrazarlo sí y por qué no
logras hazte tal vez por la
profesionalidad la objetividad
periodística por mantener una
equidistancia
tal vez al periodismo le haga falta esto
no más abrazos
pasaron muchos años de aquella
entrevista al ex combatiente otro
sobreviviente
hasta que ocurrió la tragedia de casi
salta
en el tercer o cuarto día también estaba
saliendo en vivo para un canal de
televisión
y en un momento desplegaron una bandera
con dos palabras y un símbolo las
palabras eran gracias bomberos y un
corazón
en ese momento
nos arrimamos hasta un bar que
funcionaba de alguna manera como un
centro de contención y en la pared había
leyendas
mensajes de chicos de la escuela
primaria para los bomberos y los
rescatistas
en ese momento pude leerlas en vivo y
darles un gran abrazo tal vez el abrazo
que todo el país le quiso dar
por dónde empezar
a quien preguntará algo que es
testimonio y recoger en mis años de
productor televisivo tenía un jefe que a
los periodistas quejosos por cubrir
notas de pequeño aporte les decía no vas
a tener una mía todos los días
esas son las notas fáciles de hacer
donde en cuadras tienes una historia
mientras me acercaba más y más al lugar
del desastre recordé esa frase
en cada rostro había una historia por
contar es adrenalina extraña que
segregamos los periodistas en momentos
extremos me generó contradicciones el
ocaso estaba en mi barrio mis vecinos
eran los protagonistas de que tuviera
dicho tu ex jefe que ahí tienes tu amia
pero yo no quiero contar tragedias
del periodismo
necesitamos transformarlo
con un periodismo más social
ya no nos alcanza con contar la realidad
necesitamos modificar esa realidad
narrada necesitamos derribar los muros
de las redacciones
necesitamos hacer periodismo con la
gente
de cada una de las personas los
protagonistas de las historias siempre
aprendí algo como por ejemplo con las
compañeras de mercedes delgado con
alejandra con frank o
con tu hijo autista con mi viejo y
aquella historia de florencio escardó de
todos nos llevamos algo ojalá alguna vez
podamos revertir desde el periodismo
aquella pregunta porque vienen ahora y
modificarla por un gracias por venir
gracias por venir a todos ustedes
[Aplausos]
[Música]
i